[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're gonna
see what happens
when we take our design for ninja balls,
and scale them up
to much larger balloons
holding 10 pounds of flour at once.
And then we might see what happens
if we drop that 10-pound flour balloon
off of a tall roof.
[Music]
These flour filled balloons are what
we call ninja balls or stress balls.
They're fun because they have some good
resistance when you squeeze them.
They kind of keep their shape
after we flatten them out a little bit,
and overall, there's a lot
of things you can do with them.
They work as stress balls,
they're great for juggling,
or we've shown you how you
can attach parachutes onto them,
chuck them up in the sky,
and have them float gently down.
Well today, we wanted to see
what happens if we scaled that up.
Not too long ago, we showed
you how to build this sort of
reverse vacuum chamber.
It's literally a vacuum chamber.
You attach a vacuum cleaner on to,
but with a balloon stretched
around the mouth here at the top,
and when you do that,
it inflates the balloon from the outside.
Well, while I was doing that,
I thought what else could
we fill one of these large balloons with,
other than a shark
with a laser on its head.
I thought it'd be cool to see if we
could make one of our ninja balls,
but out of much bigger balloons.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll stretch our balloon open,
fill it up with ten pounds of flour,
and then add two more
layers of balloon on top of that.
[Music]
Our balloon is now completely
stretched inside the bucket.
It's reaching every single
edge, nook, and cranny.
Now, we've got this giant wide nozzle,
and we can pour in
our 10 pounds of flour.
[Music]
The flour is in there.
Now, we're gonna take
the balloon off of this opening,
and all the air is gonna run out,
and it's gonna start spraying
flour in the air like that.
At this point, the balloon,
it has a little bit of air in it,
it's squishing the flour,
and the flour itself has a lot of air in it.
It was kind of well packed
when it was in the bag,
but as I poured it out,
it got a lot of air introduced into it,
so we have very fluffy flour
in our balloon right now,
and the balloon squeezing
is actually enough to
try and push some of that flour out
so you can see if I just let go,
it sort of starts bubbling out the top.
What we need to do is
compact this flour back down,
and to do that, we're basically
just going to take it out,
and squish it around for a while.
And I'm going to get
covered in flour today.
[Music]
There we go.
Try and tie a knot in this balloon.
One giant balloon full of flour.
Now, the goal is to
cover it in more balloons,
and to do that, we're gonna follow
the same strategy that we did
with our little ninja balls,
and we're gonna cut
the neck off of a balloon,
and try and stretch it over
what we've already got here.
First, I'm going to try and wash
it off so it's not so slippery.
So the balloon sticks
to it a little better.
This part can get a little bit tricky
because I need this balloon to stretch
enough to fit over
the balloon that's full of flour,
but I don't want it to tear,
and I want it to stay closed
enough that after its wrapped
around this balloon,
it doesn't just slide right off.
[Music]
Okay, our balloon actually
did tear a little bit fitting on there,
so now, it looks like a balloon
wearing pants that are too tight for it.
[Music]
Now it looks like a swim cap.
Sweet.
[Music]
Got layer 2 on, let's go for one more.
Alright.
There we go.
It needs its ninja mask.
[Music]
I keep wiping the balloon off
because there's flour all over the table,
and when there's too much flour,
the balloons don't like to stick
to each other, the different layers
don't and so if I try and apply a piece
of balloon over another balloon,
then it just sort of slides right off.
Alright.
I'd say now we have a giant ninja ball,
or maybe a regular-sized Yoshi egg.
It might not be quite as good
for relieving stress as the regular size.
You can't just hold it
in one hand and squish it,
and frankly, if I had this in my office,
I'd be terrified of popping it
and getting so much flour
that a professional
cleaning crew needed to come in.
I have a fairly tall building that
I'm allowed to throw stuff off of.
At least, for now.
They may kick me out after I try
this, but I'm gonna throw this off,
and see if it explodes on the ground.
We've now come to a location where
I can take this 10-pound flour-filled
Yoshi egg balloon,
and drop it off the roof.
Should be good.
[Music]
Alright, here we go.
Giant balloon Yoshi egg.
Ten pounds of flour wrapped in balloons,
let's see what happens when this
hits the ground from about 25 feet up.
[Music]
I thought it would tear right open.
Oh, that's great.
Well, the outside layer
of balloon ripped a little.
More power.
I need to throw it harder.
Alright.
I thought this was gonna tear right open,
but apparently,
that's not what it wanted to do.
We've lost our outer shell a little bit.
Our balloon ninja mask has suffered,
but the rest of it seems to be doing okay.
So, I'm gonna take it up,
and I'm just gonna throw it down.
See if I can get it to
tear open like that.
Attempt number 2.
This time with more force.
Three, two, one.
Oh my goodness!
I had no idea three balloons would
have that kind of strength behind it.
Alright.
I have an idea.
Back when we were filling these up,
I thought ten pounds of flour,
that's pretty good in a balloon.
But what would be even better
would be 25 pounds of flour.
So, I put a balloon in that bucket,
and filled it all the way up.
It's actually more like 23
and 1/2 pounds of flour,
but we're gonna try that one now.
Alright.
Let's see if we can get
this balloon out of the bucket intact.
[Music]
It's kind of bucket shaped.
There's only one layer of balloon on this.
So, if this doesn't pop,
I'm amazed at the strength of balloons,
but let's try it.
[Music]
Yeah!
That's what I was looking for.
Well, it didn't work on the first couple
of tries with the smaller balloon,
but the bigger one
with 25 pounds of flour in it,
that exploded beautifully.
That was great.
I just like dropping exploding
things off of tall buildings.
And now I have a
regular-sized ninja ball,
and we're gonna see what
happens if it lands in the flour.
[Music]
It's pretty much what I expected.
I do have one more of the 10-pound ones.
I made this before.
It doesn't have its ninja
wrapping around it,
but I think it'll probably look really
cool landing in the giant pile of flour.
It's the size of me head.
Here it goes.
[Music]
That did look cool landing
in the giant pile of flour.
Neat.
Anything else you we should be doing
with giant 10-pound balloons of flour
that are surprisingly
resistant to damage?
Ten pounds of flour
inside three layers of balloon,
a lot tougher than
I thought it was gonna be.
I thought this was just
gonna tear right open.
This is not like nice,
smooth ground either.
There's gravel, and sand,
and screws, and nails, and stuff on it.
Thought it'd shred open.
It did not.
Fortunately, we had
our 25 pound Big Bertha.
That exploded beautifully,
just what I was hoping to see,
and it also looked really cool dropping
the 10-pound ball on to the flour.
Got like a secondary
explosion out of that.
Very fun stuff.
Let us know what else
you'd like to see us do with these,
or maybe some other things you'd like
to see us drop from tall heights.
Guys, the fun doesn't end here.
There's more for you see.
The box at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will
show you that YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb in the middle,
you will be subscribed to our channel,
and that way, you'll never
miss out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then